dieser bmw ist ein problem diesel
er gehört familie hilden hütter aus dem
siegerland wegen der fahrverbote kann
das auto ab 2019 in immer weniger städte
fahren
für den familienvater ein problem denn
er ist beruflich viel unterwegs
die familie hin hütter geht es den
meisten dieselfahrer die bundesregierung
hat bislang vor allem eine lösung
betroffene sollen sich ein neues auto
kaufen
wir haben vor drei jahren neues haus
gekauft haben sehr viel investiert und
gerade bei der jungen familie ist es
nicht drin dass man sich mal gerade eben
neues auto kauft wenn es eine umrüst
möglichkeit für unseren pkw gäbe würde
ich das sehr gerne machen wir haben
gutes auto und da werde ich noch sehr
lange mitfahren können eine hardware
nachrüstung könnte diesel autos sauber
machen und vor fahrverboten schützen
doch bmw lehnt das ab als einziger
deutscher autobauer bmw chef krüger auf
der hauptversammlung mit einem
erklärungsversuch
wir sagen aber auch wenn etwas technisch
nicht sinnvoll ist die nachrüstung mit
hardware
technisch nicht sinnvoll auf nachfrage
erklärt bmw zitat eine kundin tauglicher
lösung erfordert jedoch eine
entwicklungszeit von circa drei jahren
lothar job ist bmw motorrad uner und
zeigt uns dass bmw die hardware schon
längst entwickelt hat einen eigenen
katalysator
man sieht hier schon wie der cut in
dieser form im ersatz halt katalog
abgebildet ist
die baugruppen sind auf jeden fall zu
implementieren in den unterboden die
original bmw hardware ließe sich direkt
in den bmw von lothar lau einbauen
auch ein problem diese die
entwicklungszeit im prinzip für diese
dinge die gibt es nicht weil diese teile
sind im regal beim hersteller
ist die hardware nachrüstung wirklich so
einfach wir begleiten ein experiment mit
diesem bmw x3 sechs jahre alt euro 5
diesel also von fahrverboten betroffen
zuerst müssen wir wissen wie schmutzig
ist das auto ohne die hardware das soll
ein abgastests zeigen
thomas schuster überwacht das experiment
er ist unabhängiger prüfingenieur und
axel friedrich führt die messungen durch
nicht zum ersten mal
er hat schon dutzende diesel autos
getestet für die deutsche umwelthilfe
gefahren wird in der stadt auf
landstraße und autobahn
um zu vermeiden dass das ergebnis durch
extremist beschleunigen verfälscht wird
sitzt der unabhängige prüfingenieur im
fahrzeug und kontrolliert die fahrweise
dass der testzyklus hier nicht aggressiv
gefahren wird das heißt also sehr nahe
an dem normalen fahren ist insofern ist
das definitiv vergleich bei uns sehr
aussagekräftig nach 45 minuten ist eine
messfahrt zu ende
10 messfahrten sind es insgesamt das
ergebnis der bmw x3 überschreitet den
vorgeschriebenen grenzwert von 180
milligramm stickoxide um ein vielfaches
der durchschnittswert von zehn
messfahrten 846 milligramm pro kilometer
dieser anstieg wie man jetzt hier
feststellen können
der schon ziemlich jetzt brauchen wir
für den schmutzigen bmw die hardware die
sauber machen soll
lothar taube hilft uns dabei
es ist erstaunlich einfach die hardware
für den x3 gibt es im offiziellen bmw
ersatzteilkatalog die sind direkt
nachweisbar kurzfristig bestellbar frei
haus aus den usa
wir reisen in die usa
hier gibt es die hardware die sauber
macht weil in den usa für diesel autos
schon lange strengere stickoxid
grenzwerte gelten als in europa bei
einem gebrauchtwagenhändler in
kalifornien finden wir einen bmw x3 als
us-version wir dürfen das auto näher
anschauen
und hier ist die hardware die dem x3 aus
deutschland fehlt eine blue tongue von
bmw und ein scr katalysator von bmw made
in germany das ist standard bei diesem
modell in den usa verkauft bmw diesel
autos mit scr katalysator 2008 bmw hat
die saubere hardware in den usa also
schon 2008 serienmäßig verbaut warum
nicht auch in europa eine einfache frage
bmw gibt eine komplizierte antwort zitat
neue gesetzliche anforderungen treten zu
unterschiedlichen zeiten und in
landesspezifischer form in kraft
diese anforderungen bilden den rahmen
für den wettbewerb unter den herstellern
fest steht in deutschland hat sich bmw
die technik gespart wie die anderen
autobauer auch das experiment mit dem x3
geht weiter hierbei bau motto in witten
wird der schmutzige bmw nachgerüstet die
hardware ist auch schon angekommen
alles original teile von bmw aus den usa
made in germany
also an dem unterboden sieht man ja dass
da schon entsprechende komponenten
vorgesehen war
das heißt ich habe den bau raum den ich
für das scr bauteil brauche der ist
vorhanden
da wo der katalysator hingehört es bei
unseren europäischen bmw nur ein rohr
genauso schnell wie das rohr ausgebaut
ist ist er gleich lange katalysator
eingebaut der adblue tank passt sogar
wie ein legostein in das fahrzeug und
ist kinderleicht angebracht die kosten
der nachrüstung sind überschaubar dann
bmw gibt es ja die serien komponenten
die wir entsprechend verwendet haben
und das wird sich um einen kostenblock
von 1500 euro verkaufspreis bewegen zwei
wochen später ist unser x3 zur kontrolle
im sachverständigen zentrum berlin der
prüfingenieur thomas schuster überzeugt
sich von der betriebssicherheit des
systems sowas ist ordentlich und fest
verbaut das nix abfallen kann und
irgendwo undicht ist also davon
auszugehen ist dass das system auch
ordentlich funktioniert früh am nächsten
morgen geht es los mit der abgas messung
bei sehr kalten temperaturen um null
grad eigentlich schwierige bedingungen
für eine scr system erkennen erkennen
das fahrzeug mit ein sehr gutes ergebnis
erreichen denn die haben sehr sehr
niedrige konzentrationen die wir hier
schon haben
die hardware wirkt zudem messfahrten
hatten wir bmw eingeladen doch bmw lehnt
ab der versuch sei nicht aussagekräftig
nach zehn fahrten ist das experiment
abgeschlossen
das ergebnis ist eindeutig vor der
hardware nachrüstung war der x3 sehr
schmutzig mit hardware sinken die
stickoxidwerte deutlich auf 219
milligramm pro kilometer
unter den wert den die bundesregierung
vorsieht um dieselautos von fahrverboten
auszunehmen
diese werte zeigen eindeutig dass so ein
system funktioniert die technischen
möglichkeiten sind da und die bauteile
sind bereits in den regalen von den
herstellern
also wäre es ohne probleme möglich die
fahrzeuge tatsächlich viel sauberer zu
machen
zurück bei familie hütter im siegerland
für ihren bmw wäre die hardware
nachrüstung möglich doch bmw macht nicht
mit und fühlt sich verarscht hinters
licht geführt und ich kann es nicht
verstehen weshalb bmw dann ist handelt
uns informiert und wir die möglichkeit
bekommen unsere fahrzeuge umzurüsten
hardware nachrüstung ist technisch
längst möglich doch in millionen
deutschen problem diesel bis heute nicht
eingebaut
[Musik]